le monde entier a les yeux fixés sur la
péninsule italienne tandis que tout
d'abord les troupes allemandes sous la
protection des crues convergent de nos
puissants de décès a inversé le détroit
de messine avec tout leur matériel et se
retirer sur le continent depuis et sur
de nombreux points des combats violents
dans cessé de se poursuivre
mais c'était bientôt les événements de
canard la trahison du gouvernement bat
doriot est partout et pour allemande se
trouve dans l'obligation de prendre de
grandes mesures pour leur propre
sécurité
ainsi des escales bribes avions
torpilleurs allemand recevait l'ordre de
proposer au départ des formations la
base italienne
devant la suite via honduras et a été
coulé et plusieurs unités à les antilles
pendant ce temps dans toute la
méditerranée les attaques de la loupe se
battre se multiplient contre les flottes
et les transports anjou américain